welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Voss and Rick and Morty season four is
back with a stellar premiere episode
edge of tomorrow
Rick ty Rick Pete's which does not hold
back with subtle animation jokes got
Rick's and looks like Jessica's funeral
selfie every Morty death is worth
snapshotting and obsessively zooming in
on you're interested in my Ricci and
preachy analysis of the episode and how
it defies major rules of the series
check out our after-show we explain with
special guests from the Rick and Morty
staff and subscribe to our Rick's flame
podcast feed wherever your podcast for
early audio versions of the stuff here
I'm gonna go shot by shot through this
episode to break down every detail you
might have missed to give you even more
reasons to love that Rick and Morty's
back before I begin special thanks to
current in their black card premium card
accounts for sponsoring this breakdown
mourn them in a bit three warning they
haven't seen this episode yet and let's
get started okay the episodes title is a
nod to the 2014 Tom Cruise film edge of
tomorrow live die repeat based on the
graphic novel all you need is kill the
movie is a kind of a cross between
Groundhog Day and Independence Day with
cruises repeat deaths during an alien
war resetting his day within a time loop
much like Rik in this episode the
opening scene at breakfast Morty cyber
stalks Jessica's gross funeral selfie
Instagram name Jessica hashtag Nana life
hashtag Yolo hashtag Instagram ah ah and
wearing a necklace she got from the
Jimmy Buffett theme chain restaurant
Margaritaville ever since last season's
finale Rick is now at the bottom of the
family hierarchy having to now ask
permission to take Morty on an adventure
Morty would you please accompany me to
for boat Jalan Prime for death crystals
definitely some foreboding wordplay
there with the planet named for buh
jewel on prime a place we can buy death
crystals that give you foreboding
premonitions
the opening credits tease some new shots
that may or may not be an upcoming
episodes this season there's a giant
monstrous Morty head and a space battle
who's shown up another promos we've seen
this season
a robotic morty fighting snakes maybe
these are the snakes that Rick hides in
a tube dude trick people into thinking
he has magic powers there's also a shot
of rick fighting a jacked old dude
wearing two rings maybe there's a plan
o's reference in the works there there's
another giant morty and then the family
hiding from a two-headed goose might
just be one of the joke throw away one
so they put in there
rick and morty weave through an asteroid
field similar to Han and Empire Strikes
Back and notice the asteroids have this
inner indigo tinted glow the same color
of the death crystals
presumably these asteroids crashing the
surface of what results in the geodes
where the crystals can be harvested
morty touches a crystal and gets his
first glimpse of his infinite possible
deaths which show up again again
throughout this episode is filled with
fun Easter eggs if you look at him let's
break down each of these scenarios that
we can see more deer each is up for a
book on a library top shelf and falls
off the ladder similar to his death in
the Roy VR video game morty gets fried
in electric chairs surrounded by some
interesting looking characters morty
gets pinned beneath the dumpster by the
bully morty skills off the cliff wall
that we saw him climbing in the season 4
trailer morty gets his head caught in an
elevator automatic door gets decapitated
this elevator descends the floor down
morty jokes on spaghetti beside a greedy
boab morty drives a tiny orange car gets
crushed by log similar to the death in
the scene and final destination too
similar to the premonition plot of this
episode morty checks out girls flirting
at a party and accidentally drinks
something toxic the bully slams Morty's
head with a fire extinguisher
Morty and rick drive a car off a cliff
like Thelma & Louise morty jumps off a
building it gets chopped up in
helicopter blades already opened some
Russian dolls it ends with a grenade
blows em up presumably a nod to the show
Russian dolls similar time loop
structure Morty's flesh melts away into
a skeleton morty walks on the beach and
gets hit in the head by a coconut
morty and rick spill a barrel of acid
and the car splashes it on him the
bullies stabs morty through the mouth
with a pole an older morty smokes on the
toilet and then clutches his chest a
younger Morty uses a toilet but then
gets sucked into space morty tries to
defuse the neutrino bomb from The
Vindicator episode but it explodes morty
eats a red berry that causes his head to
inflate red and pop the bully crushed
his Morty's head like that mountain did
to the Viper and Game of Thrones
Morty clutches a fence and fries and a
nuclear blast a reference to the t2
Judgment Day seen an older morty looks
at his phone while crossing the street
gets swiped by this truck it's a Servine
Institute truck I'll go back to the
rickland time episode ironically a
dealer truck hits a human this time
morty falls down the stairs more to get
stabbed while on a knife-throwing board
morty gets weighed down underwater morty
gets eaten by the bird-like creatures a
fruit peel and from the ABCs of Beth
episode tiny Rick runs across a giant
computer keyboard and the tiny morty
doesn't make the jump Morey
ODS on heroin and dies despite trying to
be resuscitated by his lover morty gets
stabbed by farmer Rick from the tales of
the Citadel episode the bully impales
naked more down a showerhead Morty's
bully chops his head off and another one
the bully stabs him with an American
flag morty opens an egg and gets
attacked by an alien style face hugger
morty dies of thirst in the desert the
bully cuts off the side with a garbage
bin and the bully freezes him in a cube
of ice and then although if you were of
them.we
to get glimpses of Rick's future deaths
which are also pretty interesting Rick
gets his head squash between two tree
trunks Rick gets crushed under a
hydraulic lift it looks like a more
t-test burster burst from Rick's chest
another alien reference Rick gets
assimilated into a mutant morty head
mass scuba Rick gets eaten by this giant
angler fish monster maybe a nod to the
unseen Rick lantus mix up adventure
Morty and Rick fall down a cave onto a
rocky surface Rick drives his ship drunk
and hits a traffic light Rick goes into
a giant play-doh shaped maker
Rick is tied up and burnt at a stake
cocoon Rick is eaten by one of the giant
telepathic spiders from the Rick's must
be crazy episode Rick is eaten by trolls
it looks like pickle Rick is eaten by a
dog giant Jack squanch from the wedding
squatches episode rips Rick in half Rick
and Morty get crushed in a trash
compactor just like the one on the Death
Star in the first Star Wars film
Rick gets murdered by a robot version of
himself and both Rick and Morty get
swallowed by a giant flower now Morty
struggled to fly the ship causes Rick to
die in the crash hallo Rick tells Morty
how to clone Rick notice that the
cloning machine includes the yellow cyan
and magenta colors of a color printer
Rick's mind wakes up in a clone in
another reality I axed this protocol
what are you doing with my clothes okay
I'm you I took my own clone bad offline
a couple seasons ago Rick is meta Lee
calling back the episode Big Trouble in
little Sanchez in which he killed off
his clones Rick realizes that this
reality and most of the alternate ones
he goes to are fascist it actually makes
sense that the fascist universes would
be the ones that kept their clone
protocols given the whole Nazi genetic
experiments that they did fascists Rick
and fascist Morty carried German Luger
pistols and their logo is a sort of
swastika formed by cross trenches the
time travel stuff box is updated each
reality to become dashes time travel
stuff shrimp time travel stuff and wasp
time travel stuff and fascists rick has
a photo shaking the hand to be now
fascist president with the note thanks
for sterilizing China kind of a callback
to last season's finale when Rick called
out how China owned the White House know
about that deal breaker China doesn't
piss on the White House well why would
they I'm sure it was expensive there's
also a hidden meaning behind the whole
character of fascists Morty but before I
continue thanks to current for
sponsoring this breakdown
current is a mobile bank account that
comes with a Visa debit card that has no
minimum balance no overdrafts and no
in these if you like me have been stung
in the past by normal bank overdraft
fee's it's no evil you know it feels a
bit like mr. goldenfold getting stung by
wasps stingers with a black premium card
account from current you get your
paycheck two days faster when he set up
your direct deposits you can even switch
over your direct deposit right in the
app current is a true debit card not a
prepaid card so you can connect it to
cash app or venmo even get cash back at
the register in stores it also works
with Apple pay and Google Wallet can
even deposit checks into your account
using the apps camera current is way
better than old banks and prepaid cards
and it only takes two minutes to sign up
and your current card will be mailed to
you for free current is available on
both iOS and Android in the United
States just go to current comm slash new
rockstars to sign up your black premium
card accounts today okay back to fascist
Morty this character when you read in
between his lines place out kind of like
an analog from the writers point of view
of the most toxic of their shows fanbase
think about it that's just Morty hates
Rick for being too political fascist
Morty pines for a vague good old days
but only talks about what he hates and
he admits that he only really likes mr.
meeseeks any screams later Rick makes
another reference to the hole alright
fringe of the fans and dropped the
Hitler stuff lost Morty's been on some
crazy message boards Rick kills fascist
Morty on this adventure with gearhead
aka Rivoli o´clock burg jr. from the
Morty night run episode and when the
meeseeks kills him they all die silently
in space as real space deaths
terrifyingly are Morty ignores the
protesting Haller Rick's they carry
signs we're here we're Scheer we see
through you go clone you're Rick we will
not be ignored stop walking through us
and there's a Berkley Hollow Rick who
carries a legalize it assign Rick
responds in a shrimp universe that is
also fascist honestly you're doing me a
huge favor by being shrimp instead of
fascists what this is shrimp dimension
includes a Nazi style Zeppelin shrimp SS
officers and shrimp German shepherds in
math class as always mr. goldenfold's
blackboard is filled with amazingly
stupid notes babies come from space 1/8
equals I'm tea dick thing another one
with VIN diagram bubbles
dick 1 s plus 1 s equals to asses m to
the a power equals T to the H power
Morty has detention along with Korey be
behind Morty is a notice forbidding
flossing no flossing and then outside
the psycho bully references Pixar's KOCO
but morty brushes them off just go with
the flow creepily either intentionally
or unintentionally morty is calling back
his assaulted by mr. jelly dean in
season 1 go with the flow you die
tomorrow no matter what it's what
bullies call a fait accompli fait
accompli is a French term meaning done
deal it's something that has already
happened by the time those who are
affected by learn about it Rick responds
again as a teddy bear but also fascist
of course it's too fascist dish nope
the lab is filled with Nazi teddy bear
regalia with old Nazi metals and other
Teddy clones incubated in the background
Morty's bully fight includes this bully
who actually saw into something Rick it
this way comes episode getting beaten up
by Jack trick and Jack's summer so
excited kind of looks like an older
version of Randall from recess and on
the wall behind them is graffiti the
initials E and H a nod to the director
of this episode Erica Hays longtime
story artist for the show police arrived
on the scene obviously this is a nod to
the anime Akira in which Tetsuo like
Morty this episode becomes an
unstoppable super soldier who transforms
into an amorphous blob when he's
consumed by his own desires using Rick's
weaponry Morty turns the cops into meat
cubes with legs
he sends a legion of me six on soldiers
rips apart their DNA melting them
turning them to ash one of them
Cronenberg's a nod to the season one
Rick potion number nine episode before
making a great gas lighting joke the
news anchor says will we all fall to his
deadly touch the episode before this the
season 3 finale showed Rick having a
technology that can kill people just by
having them touch him Rick calls back
that with jerry later this episode in
his trial morty wins over the judge
voiced by sherri shepherd by following
the death crystal to stammer the final
words of her husband I will always
remember our time in Peru he loves you
little sparrow this is a nod to another
time loop film arrival in which will
spoiler warning for a rival amy adams
uses her understanding of the future to
save the world by telling the chinese
leader of his late spouses final words
Nancy Grace comments on the trial and
notice the news ticker at the bottom no
matter how you pronounce La Croix
you sound stupid judge of Acura boy case
commit suicide center for suicide
prevention calls judges death tragic but
judges shouldn't believe in ghosts in
the sports bar watching this news
there's a banner for these squatchers a
nod of course to squanch there's also
jerseys ross 47 and smith maybe as in
jerry smith Morty Smith that's Smith 21
in Time Square this billboard for trover
saves the universe a game co-created by
Justin roiland other banners show Corp
America owns you a cologne called not
sweat an energy drink called energy
juice with a similar pink wave design as
turbulent juice in an ad for the
Broadway musical Avenue Q Rick responds
again in the wasp dimension wasis being
the most [ __ ] the insects of course
but not fully fascist we eat our prey
alive and when we don't we lay our eggs
in their eyeballs so that our young can
feast on their brains when they hatch
when you're born that big an [ __ ] the
least you can do is have a little
empathy the wasp family horrific Lee
feeds on the caterpillar version of mr.
goldenfold and then they return to
Rick's lab where Rick finds his BA Glenn
BA Glenn's were the toy puppets from the
80s and early 90s and a Kirkland Costco
brand red meeseeks what do you want in
our premiere episode 4 explain last week
writer Ryan Ridley actually revealed to
us that a red meeseeks was a longtime
pitch of his I always pitched let's do
red meeseeks
for these kind of inside takes again be
sure to subscribe to our Rick's plane
podcast feed don't tell me you gained
sentience and tried to take over what
there's some AI racist accusatory eyes
against my book Isaac Asimov wrote among
many things I Robot a story about AI
robots who turn on humans and they find
Morty in the desert overtaken by
ferrofluid in the sinister outgrowth
they free him but then it takes over
hallo Rick gives them a corporeal form
turning them evil and the wasp Rick
takes him out exactly as he foreshadowed
he would
the end of this episode wraps up
similarly to the pilot episode of the
series Beth and Jerry scold Rick for
taking Morty on a dangerous adventure
last time it was mega seeds this time
death crystals Rick gets out of it
leading to this hundred year rants jerry
pronounces akira and anime in annoyingly
over compensating attempts of a japanese
pronunciation turning our son into an
Akita i don't want to see any more anime
stuff Rick and Morty's closing rant is
crashed by summer who's heckling Rick
discovers via playback summer is
referencing doc and Marty the crude
x-rated Back to the Future parody that
royland made for channel 101 that Rick
and Morty was very loosely based on and
in the post-credits scene morty learns
the future of growing old with jessica
that he steered toward was a lie but she
only wants to work in hospice for the
lonely people no one in their lives hey
Morty quick favor cover me in gasoline
and spiders fine yeah I'm in wasn't my
first pitch but hey not gonna waste this
opportunity and the post episode tribute
is for Mike Mendel longtime emmy-winning
producer of The Simpsons and Rick and
Morty who sadly passed away this past
September the recent season premiere of
The Simpsons was also dedicated to his
memory how does this Rick and Morty
season four premiere rank among the
other season premieres Rick shank
redemption a Rick alone-time and the
pilot episode comment down below with
your thoughts and thanks again to
courage for helping us make this
breakdown again give Corrine a try at
kurt comm slash new rock stars follow me
on instagram and twitter at EA vas
follow new rock stars and socials eight
subscribed a new rock stars on youtube
and subscribe to our explain podcast
feed thank you for joining me and was it
just me or was Morty's whale kind of a
brown note just me
[Music]